senator paul
dr falchi
the idea that a government official like
yourself would claim unilaterally
unilaterally to represent science that
any criticism of you would be considered
a criticism of science itself is quite
dangerous central planning whether it be
of the economy or of science is risky
because of the fallibility of the
planner it would not be so catastrophic
if the planner were simply one physician
in peoria
then the mistakes would only affect that
physician's patients the people who
chose that physician
but when the planner is a government
official
like yourself who rules by mandate the
errors are compounded and become much
more harmful
a planner who believes he is the science
leads to an arrogance that justifies in
his mind using government resources to
smear
and to destroy the reputations of other
scientists who disagree with them in an
email exchange with dr collins you
conspire and i quote here directly from
the email
to create a quick and devastating
published takedown of three prominent
epidemiologists from harvard
oxford and stanford apparently there's a
lot of fringe epidemiologists at harvard
oxford and stanford and you quote in the
email that they were from dr collins and
you you agree that they are fringe and
immediately there's this takedown effort
a published takedown though you know
doesn't exactly conjure up the image of
a dispassionate scientist
instead of engaging them on the merits
you and dr collins sought to smear them
as fringe and take them down
and not in journals in lay press
this is not only antithetical to the
scientific method it's the epitome of
cheap politics and it's reprehensible dr
falchim
do you really think it's appropriate to
use your 420 000 salary to attack
scientists that disagree with you
the email you're referring to was an
email
of dr collins to me if you look at the
email that you responded to and hurried
up and said i can do it i can do it we
got something in wired oh no i think in
usual fashion
senator you are distorting everything
about me did you ever object to dr
collins's characterization of them as
friends did you write back to dr collins
say no they're not friends they're
esteemed scientists and it would be
beneath me i did not do that you
responded to him that you would do it
and you immediately got an article in
wired and you sent it back to him said
hey look i've got them i nailed them in
wired of all scientists
went on you
this wasn't the only time so your desire
to take down the incorrect as usual
senator you are incorrect almost
everything well no you deny you deny but
the emails tell the truth of this no
this wasn't the only time your desire to
take down those who disagree with you
didn't stop with harvard oxford and
stanford you conspired with peter dazak
who you communicated with privately and
other members of the scientific
community that wrote opinion pieces for
nature five of them signed a paper for
nature an opinion piece 17 signed a
paper that called it conspiracy theory
the idea that the virus could have
originated in the lab do you think words
like conspiracy theory should be in a
scientific paper
senator i never used that word when i
was referring to it you're distorting
virtually everything did you communicate
with the five scientists who wrote the
opinion piece in nature
where they were describing oh this
there's no way this could happen what's
on the lab me what i did you talk with
any of those scientists but keep the you
keep the story the truth it
is you thought you talked to any of the
scientists privately yes you wrote the
opinion you did
what were they telling you privately
well let me explain you know you're
going back to that original discussion
when i brought together
a group of people to look at every
possibility with an open mind so you not
only are you distorting it you are
completely turning it around
scientists that came to you privately do
they come to you privately and say no
way this came from the lab or was there
an initial impression dr gary and others
that were involved was there an initial
impression actually that it looked very
suspicious for a virus who came from a
lab senator we are here
at a committee
to look at a virus now that has killed
almost 900 000 people and the purpose of
the committee was to try and get things
out how we can help to get the american
public and you keep coming back to
personal attacks on me that have
absolutely no relevance to reality do
you think anybody has had more influence
let me finish this than you have do you
man
yes do you think it's a great success
what's happening so far do you think
you're locked out
do you think we slowed down the death
rate more people have died now under
president biden than did under president
trump you are the one responsible you
are the architect you are the lead
architect for the response from the
government and now 800 000 people have
died right so you think it's a winning
success what you've advocated for
government
senator first of all
if you look at everything that i said
you accuse me of in a monolithic way
telling people what they need to do
everything that i've said
has been in support of the cdc
guidelines wear a mask
get boosted and you've added it to make
it course take it and look at it
everything absolutely
be done
you've advocated that your infallible
opinion be dictated by law all right so
again madam chair i would like just a
couple of minutes because this
this happens all the time you personally
attacked me
and with absolutely not a shred of
evidence of anything you say so i would
like to make something clear to the
committee he's doing this for political
reasons what you need to do is he said
in front of this committee do you think
your takedown of i was prominent
epidemiologist was not political you
don't want me to finish you know what
i'm going to say that was the question
are you political and taking down these
three prominent
epidemiology paul if you would please um
i'm going to allow this uh dr fatchi to
respond we have a number of senators who
would like to ask questions and i would
like him to be able to respond please do
so
the last time we had a committee of the
time before he was accusing me of being
responsible for the death of five four
to five million people which is really
irresponsible and i say why is he doing
that there are two reasons why that's
really bad
the first is it distracts from what
we're all trying to do here today
is get our arms around
the epidemic and the pandemic that we're
dealing with
not something imaginary number two
what happens when he gets out
and accuses me of things that are
completely untrue
is that all of a sudden that kindles the
crazies out there and i have life
threats upon my life
harassment of my family
and my children without seeing phone
calls because people are lying about me
now you know i guess you could say well
that's the way it goes i can take the
hit
well it it makes a difference because as
some of you may know
just about three or four weeks ago in
december 21st
a person was arrested who was on their
way from sacramento to washington dc
at a speed stop in iowa
and they asked the police asked him
where he was going
and he was going to washington dc
to kill dr fauci and they found in his
car
an ar-15 and multiple magazines of
ammunition
because he thinks that maybe i'm killing
people so i ask myself
why would senator want to do this
so go to
rand paul website and you see
fire dr fauci with a little box that
says contribute here you can do five
dollars ten dollars twenty dollars a
hundred dollars so you are making a
catastrophic epidemic for your political
gain so you have to politically attack
your colleagues and in a politically
reprehensible only things like the
reputation okay he won't defend it no
don't argue it just simply turn around
continue this hearing we have a number
of questions after another one one more
minute please dr kauchi i i really
appreciate your response but we do have
a number of questions from senators and
we do have a second round and i'm being
asked to make sure that everybody has
their time so thank you thank you very
much for allowing me madam chair